oh i'm gonna start wearing a beanie i go
to the champions league you should wear
a beanie like we're going through like
that old
boxing like coach like come on rocky let
me try that let me see wow i'm a little
man you didn't warn me about chris
earlier
don't don't stretch it out with your
yolk but don't be shitty okay i won't
you know what you know me dude i'm a
really good friend to you oh should i go
emo brandon oh no not again dude hold on
oh no
that's you right now i miss her so much
look at him
ocean
heartbreak central that's you right now
oh 29 28 zang huh oh [ __ ] i have it the
other way around i have too many zippers
go ahead oh someone says 30 27 zang wow
what
[Laughter]
give me boxing instructions it's steve
give me box instructions right now come
on rocky yeah that's what you look like
i do come on you got the town to be a
great friend and i said you became a pup
this is what you are
wow
i called it it's what you are wow yeah
you don't want to know yeah i didn't
have a manager yeah i had no manager
rocky yeah you have the same tv there's
spit coming out of my cheeks nails yeah
nails in his gloves you look sweet i
didn't have no manager wow i want to be
a manager i'm 75 years old no how much
do you look like a [ __ ] guy that like
is still in acting class in new york
city
that's like so goddamn annoying and you
see him at the gym and you're just like
oh for [ __ ] sake it's this guy
and he's just yeah i've been doing a lot
of black boxes you know morgan freeman
made it after